this place seems to be full of traps
this game has taught me to be wary of my
surroundings was this a dark narrow
passageway with no room to roll away
better proceed carefully where's the
trap aha
a pressure plate but where what would it
trigger ah their arrows of course hmm
yes it's a good thing I was paying
attention every trap in this game can be
avoided Oh
Yolo Oh what the [ __ ] artificial
difficulty trial and error gameplay
unavoidable death the game is too hard
you'll notice I used the phrase
artificial difficulty at the end there
and some of you might be wondering what
that is artificial difficulty is a term
that became very popular around the time
Dark Souls was released for PC it refers
to a state of difficulty where failure
is unavoidable for one reason or another
for example maybe you were about to die
an unavoidable death because it was
literally impossible to tell what was
about to kill you
perhaps the camera glitched out and you
can blame the game code for your death
or maybe a boss has no apparent weakness
and requires trial and error to take
down it's rare that a game has
artificial difficulty in a pure form
because most circumstances that lead to
failure are completely avoidable games
like Dark Souls are unique in that they
require to the player to be in a
constant state of skill and awareness to
stop them being punished make one
mistake because you missed an
environmental clue or opportunity and
you may find that you died or that you
had your character disadvantaged in some
way and in my opinion this is the best
kind of difficulty it's the kind where
you are rewarded for paying attention or
exploring and Dark Souls does this
exceptionally well for example there's
bloodstains on this platform leading up
to the spikes on the roof
there's corpses bloodstains and child's
stone on this bridge that gets burned by
a dragon there's a key that unlocks a
shortcut further past this boss room and
there's a ladder here which allows you
to do a plunging attack which you should
have learnt in the tutorial this is a
game where you learn which way to go
because an area is too hard rather than
have a huge compass on your screen at
all times like most modern games in the
edge article about Dark Souls 2 should
goo your talks of enhancing these clues
and rewards and that's one of the things
I'm most excited for artificial
difficulty states that you shouldn't
have to learn through trial and error I
personally like trial and error gameplay
learning from your mistakes is what
makes the better player however I
understand why many people complain
about trial and error gameplay some
fights like the bed of chaos or Capra
demon almost require you to fail before
you can try again with the Capra demon
you are thrust into an intense fight
where it's almost impossible
to take in your surroundings before you
can make a plan it would have been
better in my opinion if you could
observe the room beforehand with the bed
of chaos we have a boss fight that was
poorly thought out because you are
likely to die no matter how many times
you've done the fight additionally when
you open a mimic chest you were going to
die the first time you do so with no
warning unless you read the art book of
course these are examples of difficulty
that could have been done better
since skill plays less of a part in
these than trial and error does so let
me know what you think for the most part
I think Dark Souls does difficulty
really well and I don't want to see this
style change in the next Souls game we
receive Dark Souls is set apart from
most modern games not because it is
incredibly difficult but because it
handles difficulty really damn well